my first job out of college was as an
academic researcher at one of the
largest juvenile detention centers in
the country and every day I would drive
to this building on the west side of
Chicago
go through the security checkpoint and
walk down these brown brick hallways as
I made my way down to the basement to
observe the intake process the kids
coming in were about 10 to 16 years old
usually always black and brown most
likely from the same impoverished south
and west sides of Chicago they should
have been in 5th to 10th grade but
instead they were here for weeks on end
awaiting trial for various crimes some
of them came back to the facility 14
times before their 15th birthday and as
I sat there on the other side of the
glass from them idealistic with a
college degree
I wondered to myself why didn't schools
do something more to prevent this from
happening it's been about 10 years since
then I still think about how some kids
get tracked towards college and others
towards detention but I no longer think
about schools abilities to solve these
things you see I've learned that so much
of this problem is systemic that often
our school system perpetuates the social
divide it makes worse what it's supposed
to fix that's as crazy or controversial
as saying that our health care system
isn't preventative but somehow profits
off of keeping us sick oops
I truly do believe though that kids can
achieve great things despite the odds
against them and in fact my own research
shows that but if we are serious about
helping more kids from across the board
to achieve and make it in this world
we're gonna have to realize that our
gaps and student outcomes are not so
much about achievement as much as they
are about opportunity a 2019 IDI build
report showed that majority white
districts receive about twenty three
billion dollars more in annual funding
than non-white districts even though
they serve about the same number of
students lower resource schools are
dealing with lower quality equipment
obsolete technology and paying teachers
way less here in New York those are also
the school's most likely to serve the
one in ten elementary school students
who will most likely have to sleep in a
homeless shelter tonight the student
parent and teacher are dealing with a
lot but sometimes places are miss
placing the blame back on them in
Atlanta we saw that teachers felt
desperate enough to have to help their
students cheat on standardized tests
that would impact their funding eight of
them went to jail for that in 2015 with
some sentences as high as twenty years
which is more than what many states give
for second-degree murder
the thing is though in places like Tulsa
teachers pay has been so bad
that these people have had to go to food
pantries or soup kitchens just to feed
themselves the same system will
criminalize a parent who will use a
relative's address to send their child
to a better school but for who knows how
long authorities have turned a blind eye
to those who can bribe their way onto
the most elite and beautiful college
campuses and a lot of this feels pretty
heavy to be saying and maybe to be
hearing and since there's nothing quite
like economics talk to lighten the mood
that's right right let me tell you about
some of the costs when we fail to tap
into our students potential a McKinsey
study showed that if in 1998 we could
have closed our long-standing student
achievement gaps between students of
different ethnic backgrounds or student
of different income levels by 2008 our
GDP or untapped economic gains could
have gone up by more than 500 billion
dollars those same gaps in 2008 between
our students here in the US and those
across the world may have deprived our
economy of up to two point three
trillion dollars of economic output but
beyond economics numbers and figures I
think there's a simpler reason that this
matters a simpler reason for fixing our
system is that in a true democracy like
the one we pride ourselves on having and
sometimes rightfully so a child's future
should not be predetermined by the
circumstances of their birth a public
education system should not create a
wider bottom and more narrow top some of
us can sometimes think that these things
aren't that close to home but they are
if we brought in a review because leaky
faucet in our kitchen broken radiator in
our hallway those parts of the house
that we always say we're gonna get to
next week they're devaluing our whole
property instead of constantly looking
away to solutions like privatization or
the charter school movement to solve our
problems why don't we take a deeper look
at public education try to take more
pride in it and maybe use it to solve
some of our social problems why don't we
try to reclaim the promise of public
education and remember that it's our
greatest collective responsibility
luckily some of our communities are
doing just that
the huge teacher strikes in the spring
of 2019 and Denver and LA they were
successful because of community support
for things like smaller class sizes and
getting things in the schools like more
counselors in addition to teacher pay
and sometimes for the student innovation
is just daring to implement common-sense
in Baltimore a few years ago they
enacted a free breakfast and lunch
program taking away the stigma of
poverty and hunger for some students but
increasing achievement and attendance
for many others and in Memphis the
university is recruiting
local passionate high school students
and giving them scholarships to go teach
in the inner city without the burden of
college debt and north of here in the
Bronx I recently researched these
partnerships being built between high
schools community colleges and local
businesses who are creating internships
in finance healthcare and technology for
students without Silverspoon connections
to gain important skills and contribute
to the communities that they come from
so today I don't necessarily have the
same questions about education that I
did we know when I was an idealistic
perhaps naive college grad working in a
detention center basement it's not can
school save more of our students because
I think we have the answer to that and
it's yes they can if we save our schools
first we can start by caring about the
education of other people's children and
I'm saying that as someone who doesn't
have kids yet but wants to worry a
little bit less about the future for
what I do
cultivating as much talent as possible
getting as many girls as we can from all
over into science and engineering and as
many boys as we can into teaching those
are investments for our future our
students are like our most valuable
resource and when you put it that way
our teachers are like our modern-day
diamond and gold miners hoping to help
make them shine let's contribute our
voices our votes and our support to
giving them the resources that they will
need not just to survive but hopefully
thrive allowing all of us to do so as
well thank you
[Applause]
[Music]